(upbeat ambient music)
- Hi, I'm Jacob Andreas, I'm
an assistant professor at MIT
and ECS and CSAIL and I work on
natural language processing.
So sort of broadly, my
group is interested both in
developing better technologies,
better machine learning
models for working with
data from human languages
and looking at what we
can do with language
in support of other kinds
of artificial intelligence
applications.
Doing things like building
robots that you can
teach using natural language
or computer vision systems
that can explain their
decisions also in language
and today I'm gonna be
answering your questions
about large language models,
what are large language models
and how do they generate text?
When you're typing on your
phone and you see that
little sort of line that
pops up with some guesses
about the word that's
gonna come next, that's a
language model and sort
of fundamentally what most
of the language models that we work with
are just predictive models
of text models that have
been trained on enormous
amounts of text data
to look at a sentence or
the beginning of a sentence
or look at the document in the beginning
of a document and just
predict what words are likely
to come next, how are LLMs
large language models trained?
Sort of building on that previous
answer, the big difference
between a large language model
that you might have heard
of like GPT-3 and the language
model that sort of sits there
doing predictive text on your
phone is really just the scale
of the data that it's been
trained on and the biggest models
that we have right now
have really been trained
more or less on most of
the text on the internet.
They're sort of enormous machine
learning models with really
really high capacity that
have just been sort of trained
to do that same next word
prediction task but on a much,
much, much broader diversity
of documents set of
kinds of text languages
of documents and so on
than the one that sits on your phone.
What are some of the key
technical innovations
that have enabled the development
of large language models?
So language models, it's
important to note have been around
for a long time, really since
the very earliest days of
natural language processing.
So when people were first
setting out to build
automatic speech recognition
systems, really sort of
at the dawn of computer
science there was always
this problem of figuring
out, well if I have
a couple of different ways
of interpreting the audio
that I'm hearing, which of
those is actually likely
to be the sequence of
words that people meant?
And even then, people sort
of trained these kinds
of predictive text models
that could look at a sentence
and guess what word was
coming or tell you whether
a sentence was likely or not.
And so these have been with
us for a very long time
and the reason that I think
most people are hearing
about them now, or the big
thing that's sort of different
in the last three or five
years is just sort of
how much bigger and how
much better these models
have gotten.
of widespread use of
artificial neural network
machine learning models as
models for language processing.
These have also been around,
really for a long time,
like since the sixties
but various developments
have kind of converged in
the last couple of years,
That means that we're able to train them
at a very large scale,
we're able to train them
on a large amount of data
and they just work super,
super well and so what we're
seeing with sort of large
language models today
is a sort of convergence
of better hardware
for training neural network
models, some basic innovation
in how those neural
network models are trained
and then just enormous amounts
of data on the internet
that allows us to train them
at a really large scale,
how do language models differ
from traditional approaches
to natural language processing?
So maybe one of the
other biggest differences
between these models that
we're seeing right now
and even the kinds of
language models that people
were building, you know when
I was in graduate school
not very long ago is that
we bake very little about
the structure of natural
language into them ahead of time
and so it used to be that
a large part of the work
in natural language processing
was sort of taking our
understanding of how languages
are structured, how sort of
syntax works, how the morphology
of individual words work
and building that into specialized
machine learning models
that can used this information
to make better predictions.
And with many of the kinds
of models that we're training
right now you don't
necessarily have to bake all
of that information in from
the beginning and instead
these models learn just from reading large
or I guess training on
large amounts of data
what the structure of
language is and how it works.
Now this is not to say
that sort of knowledge
about linguistic structure
is not useful for NLP,
it's certainly the case that
in languages without large
digitized training sets or
with small numbers of speakers
being able to build models
that really do have access
to sort of rich information
about linguistic structure
is still important.
And our understanding
of how language works
can inform the ways in
which we test these models
to make sure that they're
working and the ways we sort of
probe their internal
reprensantations to figure
out how it is they work.
But I guess the biggest
difference between the way
we're doing things now and
the way we were doing things
even five years ago or 10
years ago, is that most
of that structure sort of
gets used after the fact
and not when we are training
models from the onset.
What are some of the challenges involved
in training and deploying
large language models?
And maybe the biggest challenge
which I've been alluding to
a little bit already is just
the fact that these models
require huge amounts of
computing power to train
and so nowadays the kinds of
models that you've heard about
things like, like ChatGPT or
Llama have been trained on
hundreds or thousands of
GPUs for hours and hours
and hours and hours and
this presents a couple of
different challenges.
It both just requires an
enormous amount of energy
to train these models, the
training process itself
is complicated, it's sort
of the idea of training
a machine learning model at
the scale for such a long time
is not something that we've
done until relatively recently
in the machine learning world or in the
natural language processing
world and so a lot of the
challenge really comes in training.
And I think this is
part of the reason that,
there are only a small
number of these models
out there that you know
sort of most people are
interacting with or that
most people have heard of
because training even
one of them is just like
a really complicated and
really costly endeavor
requiring huge teams of people
and hundreds of thousands
or millions of dollars
and as there's a result is
the sort of thing that
people are only doing
relatively infrequently.
Why do the most prominent
large language models
all have effectively the same architecture
and what is the architecture
of a transformer model?
Many of the biggest language
models that we're sort
of seeing released to the
public right now are based
on a particular neural
network architecture called
the Transformer that was
introduced around 2017.
And the way a transformer
works is basically
you sort of take a chunk of text as input
whether it's a sentence or
a paragraph or a document
and you look at individual
words or sometimes pieces
of words in that document
and you represent them
as actually points in a very,
very high dimensional space.
You then apply a series of
operations that are called
attention to those points
where every point sort of looks
at all of its other neighbors
decides to wiggle itself
around a little bit in
that space and then all
of the neighbors do the same thing.
And you repeat this process
over and over and over again
till eventually you sort
of take one of those points
you figure out which
word it's now closest to
which is probably not the
word that it started out
closest to and that
becomes the model's output
at the next time step.
These transformer models
are not the only way to
build a language model or
even a neural network based
language model and one of
the reasons that I think
we're seeing such a dominance
of this kind of transformer
architecture in the last couple of years
is that they're really easy
to train at a large scale.
And so I mentioned before that
these sorts of computational
constraints are one of the big
issues or the big challenges
that come up when training
these language models
and these transformer type models turn
out to be particularly
well suited to training
in a distributed way,
training at a large scale
and I think that's one of the
reasons that we've started
to see so much of them right now.
But it's important to mention
that's not the only way
to build a language model
and it wouldn't surprise me
if in the next couple of
years we actually start to see
greater diversity in the kinds
of neural language models
even that people are training.
What are some promising
ways to use these models
and especially ways of
using these models beyond
the language and code
applications that many people
have seen?
Taking a step back, why are
we here, why are we doing this
explainer?
Why is there so much
interest in language models
in the first place?
And I think a big part of this
is that, starting with this
very simple task of
predicting what word is going
to come next in a document
turns out to give models
that are capable of
accomplishing a wide variety
of other useful things right?
So sort of mentioning ways of language app
or using these models in the context
of language applications, if
I am trying to write an essay
and I type in a question
or a prompt that says
something like what were the
causes of the first world war?
A good guess at what kind of
language is gonna come next
if you're a good auto
complete model is an essay
or is a sort of detailed
answer that actually addresses
those questions.
And what this means is
that a lot of things that
we haven't sort of
traditionally thought of as
things that language models
are for or even things
that are kind of within the domain of
natural language processing
as a field to tackle
you can actually pose as
these kinds of next word
prediction problems with
appropriate prompts.
And what this means is that we
can use these language models
to do a ton of different things.
And so as the question gets
at a lot of the applications
that people have seen so
far really build directly
on this kind of text
auto complete paradigm,
you're sitting in your text
editor in your Microsoft Word
or Google Docs, you type
in some instructions
or you type in the sort
of beginning of a document
and you ask the model to
guess what's gonna come next.
And sometimes that's the text
or at least close to the text
that you already wanted
to write and similarly
in these kinds of programming
applications right,
you type in a comment and if
you have a really good model
that model can often guess
what code should come
at come after that comment.
Especially if it's really,
the sort of boiler plate code
that many of us find ourselves
writing over and over again
that we know other people out
there have already written
many times and maybe even
posted inversions that exist
on the internet.
All that said I think we're
likely to see these models
showing up in all kinds of
other interesting places,
even in sort of problems that
on the surface maybe seem
not to have anything to do
with text or anything to do
with programming at all.
So one thing that my group,
for example has been thinking
a lot about recently is
what we can learn from text
or what we can sort of
extract from language models
about how the world works in a general way
that we can then use to
support computer vision
or sort of improve models
for robotics or models
for computer vision.
So if you're trying to
accomplish some sort of
difficult household task, cleaning a room,
cooking a complicated meal,
there's a lot of common sense
knowledge that's sort
of difficult to get from
traditional robotics or
computer vision training sets,
what kinds of objects are
likely to co-occur together?
What sensible place in
your living room is to set
down this pillow that you just picked up,
where in the kitchen you're
likely to find a teapot
or tea bags or things like that.
And what's amazing is that
language models, again just
by sort of virtue of doing
this next word prediction task
know a lot of these things as
well and so if you query them
in the right ways and
at the right times, you
can actually use them to
fix or improve or guide
the outputs, even if models
for like robotics tasks
and computer vision tasks
where there might not
actually be any language
as an input or as an output
to the model.
How do multilingual transformers
handle different languages
and dialects?
You know, one other thing
that we're starting to see
in the models that people
are training right now
or at least in many of
the largest scale models
is that they're trained not
just on a single language
but on many, many different languages,
maybe as many different
languages as we can get our
hands on.
And this is a really
important development for
a long time in the history of
natural language processing
as a field, a lot of the
research was being done
just in English sort of building
models that were trained
only on data in English or even
that worked only on English
even if you tried to train
them on other data sets.
Now this is certainly, not
what everybody's been doing
and there's a long sort
of history going back
to the earliest days of the
field of trying to do NLP
for other languages.
But if you just look at
most of the papers that are
getting published at our
sort of top NLP conferences
a lot of the work is in English
and so one thing that we see
when we train these models
on multilingual data is that,
not only do they sort of
acquire the ability to do all
of these impressive
things, not just in English
but in other languages
as well but that actually
you often benefit especially
in the smallest languages
by sort of training models
at this large scale.
So there's a sense in which
models can sort of take skills
that they acquired from tasks
that were specified in English
and the training data and can
generalize those to languages
that maybe were sort of so
sparsely represented in the data
that they don't have examples
of every individual task
that a model is solving.
And so I guess an
important feature of these
multilingual transformers
is just that they not only
can they handle different
languages and dialects,
but that they get better
especially at those sort of
least represented languages
and dialects as these scales
get bigger.
Now, an important caveat
there of course is that
our performance with these
models in English is still
far ahead of most of the
other languages that we can
train them on, there's still
enormous need for technologies
that serve people that
are not sort of speakers
of the world's five
most frequent languages
or users of those languages.
And while these multilingual
models are an important
first step in that direction,
I think there's still a lot
of work to do both on the modeling side
and really especially on
the benchmarking side,
just to give us a kind of
clear picture of how well
these tools work outside
of English and especially
in less common languages,
what are the limitations
of large language models and
how can they be addressed?
This is a big question and you
know I think one of the most
important ones is what we
were talking about just
a minute ago with regard to
sort of how well they work
in different languages and even
just understanding how well
they work for different kinds of users.
But there are also sort
of user specific questions
aside a couple of like
really fundamental issues
that even the biggest
models that we have today
still face one of them
has to do with factuality,
so it's well documented that
these models hallucinate facts
that they're not always reliable.
I can't remember why I was
doing this, but recently
asked ChatGPT to describe
some of our group's research
and it named five papers
four of which are not papers
that actually exist and one
of which is a real paper
that was written by a
colleague of mine who lives
in the United Kingdom who
I've never co-authored with,
so factuality is still a big problem.
And even sort of beyond that
things involving reasoning
in a really general sense things involving
sort of complicated computations,
complicated inferences
still seem to be really, really
difficult for these models
and might be even sort of
fundamental limitations
of this transformer
architecture and are I think
somewhere where a lot more
modeling work is needed
to make things better,
can large language models
understand context?
Also an interesting question
and I think depends on
a lot on what you mean
by context, so certainly
when we think about linguistic
contexts these models
are capable of sort of reasoning
about much, much longer
documents and sort of
chunks of text more broadly
than really anything that we've
known how to build before.
But that's only one kind
of context and people write
production language comprehension
takes place in sort of
grounded context.
That I know I'm sitting at
this table there are objects
that I can refer to
and the language models
that we have right now,
when they're interacting
with a human user typically
can't see any of that.
There's a broader social
context that informs a lot
of our language use and also
that these models are at least
not sort of immediately sensitive
to or where it's not clear
how to give them information
about the social context
in which their language
generation and language modeling
takes place.
Another important thing is,
I guess temporal context,
that we're sort of shooting this video
at a particular moment in
time when particular facts
are true.
The models that we have right
now, we're sort of trained
on, again a snapshot of
the internet that stopped
at a particular time.
For most models that we
have now probably a couple
of years ago and they
don't know about anything
that's happened since then,
they don't even know sort of
at what moment in time
they're doing text generation
and so figuring out how
to provide all of those
different kinds of contexts is
also an interesting question.